[Music]
Donald Trump the only president who
combines the sordid extramarital affairs
of a young JFK with the dead-eyed
puffiness of a post-watergate Richard
Nixon look I know we have talked about
Trump a lot on this show but tonight
we'd like to do it from a slightly
different angle and that is focusing on
his relationship with the world because
while we were away you may remember one
particular remark he made according to
the US president Africa is a
that's right he said that he absolutely
said that except to be fair to him it's
actually worse because he reportedly
called Africa Haiti and El Salvador
holes which is just not okay and I do
acknowledge that I personally have
called Belgium a multiple times
but in my defense a I'm not president
and be Belgium is a load some chocolate
gulag with no objective reason to exist
so you can see that it's very different
you can see that and look you probably
saw people on u.s. TV being justifiably
appalled by those remarks but what you
may not have seen is the response from
the countries he insulted honestly so
sure then she's like has he ever
we not sit home we people we just like
it is a yes because it doesn't
matter what you have he's still going to
the same hole we're the same worms will
eat into Wow
you know it says something about the
Trump era that the phrase the same worms
will eat into actually qualifies as a
hopeful thought I would honestly like
that crocheted on a pillow so I can wake
up to it every morning and look look it
is not like that's the only time that
Trump's remarks have caused an
international uproar he said that Korea
used to be part of China which outraged
South Koreans he claimed that Germany
owes NATO vast sums of money which it
does not and in the UK he retweeted
these anti-muslim videos from a
far-right British group which triggered
massive condemnation and instead of
fully apologizing for it he said it was
a big story where you are but it was not
a big story where I am and that is
exactly his attitude if it wasn't big
where I could see it then it wasn't big
so forget mastering foreign affairs
Trump may not have mastered object
permanence which you really need to be a
good president or even a good
baby and yet here is the crucial thing
the rest of the world continues to exist
whether Trump acknowledges or not so
tonight let's try and answer a few basic
questions at first what is Donald
Trump's foreign policy because it seems
to be little more than repeating a
single phrase America first America
first America first again America first
America first it will be America first
from now on
America first now if you are another
country watching that you may well be
wondering wait
when has America's attitude ever not
been America first they've been putting
America first since the day they arrived
in America very much second but say here
Donald Trump telling in recent years
we've been getting the short end of the
stick on the campaign trail he often
complained that America had become a
global punch line and promised that he
could reverse that the world is laughing
at us folks the whole world is laughing
at us they're laughing at this that's
what's going on in our country the world
laughs at us folks the world laughs at
us we're not gonna be a laughingstock
like we have been and we have been
believe me oh we're not going to be a
laughingstock anymore huh it is insane
that Trump this guy this guy this guy
thought he would end the laughter it's
like a flamingo in boxer shorts named
Phineas J rocket dump ran for president
under the slogan time to get serious now
for the record since Trump became
president if anything the world is
laughing harder than ever before because
while all US presidents do get made fun
of impersonating Trump has become an
international cottage industry Israel
has Trump kicking a Muslim man while
dancing lewdly to guns and roses Germany
has him dancing to Uptown funk
Spain has him flipping off the world and
again dancing like an idiot and there's
more here he is in Pakistan here he is
in Bulgaria here he is in Taiwan
here he is in Ethiopia here's a pretty
shitty one from Turkey where they're not
even trying
here's a Korean Trump and here's one
from an Italian comedy show see him born
in the USA on a stealth fighter before
being taken out with a bucket on his
head
are any of these funny I don't know is
anything about trunk funny anymore
somehow the world's most objectively
laughable human has become a comedy
graveyard when laughter goes to die and
in case you think any of that may have
been good-natured ribbing a recent
Gallup poll shows that the world's
approval rating of US leadership has
dropped to 30 percent after being at
nearly 50 percent just two years ago
that is a precipitous drop in popularity
is the equivalent of replacing gal gadot
in the Wonderwoman franchise with Matt
Lauer look I know I love the Donald
Trump and others may not give a
about what the world thinks about us but
they really should for a number of
reasons chief among them something
called soft power which yes I
acknowledge does sound like an erectile
dysfunction medication for chinchillas
so soft yet so hard but but basically
basically refers to the ability to get
others to do what you want them to do
without using carrots or sticks it's
kind of a country's brand and a nation
soft power can come from many sources
from your pop culture to the ideals you
express to your reputation and diplomacy
can play a major part in it even hard
power practitioners like Trump's own
Secretary of Defense Jim Mad Dog mattis
supports the soft power work that's done
by the State Department that is why a
few years back he gave a full-throated
defense of properly funding it frankly
they need to be as as fully funded as
Congress believes appropriate because if
you don't fund the State Department
fully then I need to buy more ammunition
ultimately now that is scary because buy
more ammunition is his way of saying
without diplomacy there will be more
Wars
he doesn't need more ammunition so he
can make more bullets earrings for his
Etsy store because he's not just
Secretary of Defense he also crafts
accessories for the elegant weirdo now
unfortunately though Trump has shown
little interest in soft power his
administration recently proposed a 29
percent cut to the State Department and
foreign aid and there are
any high-level vacancies at the State
Department to say nothing of our lack of
ambassador's from Belgium to Belize
South Korea to South Africa President
Trump has a problem
his embassies have no ambassador Turkey
Jordan Egypt Qatar and Saudi Arabia all
without ambassadors holy
South Korea Turkey and Saudi Arabia
those are countries where you really
need an ambassador it's not like Lipson
Stein where you can basically scrape by
with a sign that says never stop
Lichtenstein II and as for the
ambassadors that Trump has appointed
some of them are frankly not grapes when
Trump appointed Peter Hoekstra
ambassador to the Netherlands they were
a little upset over there as this
interview shows speaking of threat at
one point you mentioned in a debate that
there are no go zones in the Netherlands
and that cars and politicians are being
set on fire and then I didn't say that
that is actually an incorrect statement
yeah we would call it fake news okay
okay I didn't say that so and so he's
given himself some wiggle room there as
long as he didn't say exactly what the
reporter just claimed about no-go zones
and politicians being set on fire he's
technically correct the only thing in
the whole world
that would make him not correct is if
say video of him saying that cars and
politicians are being bird and that yes
there are no go zones in the Netherlands
there are cars being burned there are
politicians that are being burned and
yes there are no go zones in the
Netherlands it's pretty weird not to
recall saying out loud there are
politicians that are being burned in the
Netherlands it's not the kind of thing
that you do and immediately forget about
like driving to work or seeing the movie
the post I mean I have a vague memory of
walking into a darkened room eating Milk
Duds and thinking Meryl Streep is a
treasure but the rest is a complete
blank
but when Trump was asked about his
understaffed State Department he claimed
that it didn't really matter for one key
reason let me tell you the one that
matters is me I'm the only one that
matters because when it comes to it
that's what the policy is going to be
I'm the only one that matters the only
one that matters is me it's hard to tell
if Donald Trump is laying out a
diplomatic strategy or demanding that
daddy buy him an oompa loompa then his
actions are critical to our nation's
foreign policy and that brings us to our
next question how is his approach to the
world going and the answer surprisingly
is great and now this I'm kidding it's
been a disaster
in fact to give you a sense of how much
damage he can do in very little I can't
believe you nearly bought that he could
do a very little time just look at last
summer's back-to-back NATO and g7 summit
it was just three days of meetings in
which time he reportedly told European
leaders that quote the Germans are bad
very bad then shook Emmanuel krons hands
so aggressively it seemed like he was
trying to masturbate an elephants then
at the g7 conference the next day world
leaders unsuccessfully tried to convince
him to stay in the Paris climate Accord
and in the middle of all of that he gave
a speech where he failed to explicitly
reaffirm article 5 the basic principle
that NATO members should come to the aid
of each other when attacked affirming it
is routine for presidents and it was
even in Trump speech until being
apparently deleted at the very last
minute blindsiding top members of his
own national security team and after
witnessing Trump's erratic behavior for
just three days Angela Merkel was so
shell-shocked
she made this statement the times when
we could completely rely on others are
to an extent / I've experienced this in
the last few days and that's why we
Europeans must really take our fate into
our own hands that was the day after the
summit
I wasn't even supposed to give a major
speech that was at a campaign event held
in a beer tent and that means we're
probably lucky there was an event of any
kind otherwise she would have just
yelled out Europe is on its own at her
nephew's piano recital and this brings
us to our final question what are the
consequences of this well one big one of
them could be that there is a leadership
vacuum in the world so who will fill
that well in Europe the obvious
candidate is Germany but even they know
that there may be an issue with that
well whenever I talk to people in our
neighbor countries they mostly expected
sort of the leadership of Germany but on
the other side whenever I talk to the
people in these countries with a very
good memory what happened in the first
half of the 20th century they are very
reluctant talking about a German
leadership you're right you're right I'm
so glad that you brought that up because
I I didn't want to be the first one to
bring it up but you are absolutely right
when people hear Germany wants to take a
leading role in Europe most of us do
still think no they're still in timeout
and they know why they know what they
did not see Germany now now globally it
seems that China is set to be the
biggest beneficiary because they have
been aggressively seeking to increase
their influence and soft power something
that has not gone unnoticed a nation
head of government recently explained to
me that at every regional conference
Washington sends a couple of diplomats
whereas Beijing sends dozens the Chinese
are there at every committee meeting and
you are not he said the result he
explained is that Beijing is
increasingly setting the Asian agenda
it's true the u.s. is absent at many
important meetings and that doesn't even
include meetings that Jared Kushner was
supposed to attend but he couldn't find
a room and he was too shy to ask someone
and then he realized it was too late
anyway so he just killed an hour
wandering around the lobby pretending to
be on the phone
and the piglets China's increased
influence should be alarming because
they are an autocratic country you don't
necessarily want China setting global
priorities on things like human rights
and democracy and yet
Trump's reckless behavior is opening the
door to exactly that happening not to
mention the fact that what he's doing is
going to make it harder for him to
accomplish his own goals he wants to
contain North Korea or to do that you
might want to appoint an ambassador to
South Korea he wants Germany to spend
more on its military okay but maybe stop
publicly shaming Merkel if you want her
to be able to sell that idea back home
and it wants to contain security threats
like Isis and Al Shabaab in African
countries then maybe don't call African
countries shitholes truck can
say that he doesn't care because his
approach is America first but you need
allies to get anything done
foreign affairs is like sex if you
loudly announce that you will always
come first
you're going to have trouble finding
partners and as for on to other promise
that the world will stop laughing it is
not just comedians doing that it's world
leaders Australian Prime Minister
Malcolm Turnbull was a depressed in the
last year and he had himself a bit of
fun Donald I we are we and we
face pulse they're the ones we're not.we
we're waiting in the real balls get out
of the online bones
they also guy
that is a key ally using the fact that
our president is a pathological liar as
a punchline and crushing that room like
a fourth grader with a carrot stick
stuck up his nose anything think that
was grim let me show you one more clip
we found when we were looking for Trump
impersonators around the world this one
is from Russian TV with a comedian
making fun of Trump's suspiciously close
relationship to Putin and there is a fun
little surprise for you
just at the end Hillary the other day
Hillary asked me Donald do you love
Russia I answered yes I do I love Russia
but you have no evidence against me
by God that is as happy as I've ever
seen Putin ever I guess at least we now
know what type of humor that Putin likes
he likes the kind where he medals in
another country's election succeeds has
a joke about it made to his face in
public and then realizes it all worked
out no one can touch him that's the kind
of humor that Putin likes it just
creases him up look I know that all of
this is depressing because it seems like
America's reputation overseas is under
attack from its own president which is
just ridiculous soft power is an act of
salesmanship it's selling your brand it
is the one thing that Trump is supposed
to be good at and he's blowing
it
so as an immigrant who has fallen in
love with this country for what it's
worth please allow me to speak to the
rest of the world in America's defense
for a moment because Donald Trump does
not reflect America I mean to be to be
completely honest to be completely
honest who does reflect it a bit but the
point is America is not one thing it's a
beautiful mess of contradictions where
good and bad are mixed together on one
hand it makes Mountain Dew which tastes
like a honeydew melon was by a
radioactive cloud on the other hand it
also made this awesome bed shaped like
the Batmobile you can fall asleep in
that thing and be Batman if Batman
somehow got locked out of the Batcave
and had to sleep in his car but that's
the American dream right there America
is the country that came up with YouTube
which yes I know gave you in the world
that head Logan Paul but it also
gave you those videos of adults in t-rex
suits on dirt bikes ballet dancing
exercising and doing basic car repairs
and by the way that magnificent dinosaur
costume that's an American idea to that
the point is America is the country that
gave you Star Wars
you're welcome and Scientology who were
sorry about that and and sometimes
what's great and terrible about us is
just impossible to separate like look
Popeyes Chicken
it's objectively disgusting but I would
run across traffic to eat this but
the point is trevor is the worst of us
yes but he's not all of us if I did is
still America down to one sound it
wouldn't be the braying voice of Donald
Trump screaming America first it would
be the gorgeous voices of the New York
City gay men's chorus singing this song
[Applause]
that's right that's all star by
smashmouth a terrible stupid songs being
sung absolutely beautifully this should
be our new national anthem and so please
world
[Applause]
[Music]
embarrassment the country to incredible
dinosaur costumes
[Applause]